es ist das Jahr 2002 Deutschlands
größter Stromanbieter will mit
Deutschlands größtem Gasanbieter
fusionieren ein Mega-Konzern soll
entstehen Wettbewerbshüter warnen vor
den Risiken
wenn man die rechtlichen Grundlagen der
Fusionskontrolle sich anguckt
t war gar kein Zweifel dass da am Markt
beherrschende Stellungen verstärkt
werden
trotz heftiger Kritik die
Bundesregierung erteilt grünes Licht per
Erlass wird der Mega Deal besiegelt
letztlich muss man sagen die genauen
Hintergründe sind schon eher skandalös
die zu der Ministererlaubnis damals
geführt haben ist
ziemlich offensichtlich
dass alles im Vorhinein besprochen haben
so wird Deutschland immer abhängiger von
russischem Gas
man ist in dieser Abhängigkeit gekommen
weil die einseitige Ausrichtung auf
gazpromen zur Strategie von rohrgas
gehörte die Spätfolge der Megafusion
Juniper Deutschlands größter und
wichtigster gasversorger in finanzieller
Schieflage seit Russland den Gasern
zudreht die Rettung nur mit staatlicher
Hilfe möglich und Steuergeldern in
Milliardenhöhe
wäre das damals anders entschieden
worden hätten wir heute eine
vielfältigere wettbewerbspolitisch
sinnvolle Situation
alles fängt an mit der Vorstellung der
Regierung Schröder Deutschlands Konzerne
müssten als Champions im globalen Markt
mitmischen
zu dieser Vision gehört auch ein
Energiekonzern der vor allem mit Hilfe
deutsch-russischer gasgeschäfte zum
Global Player im Vorsteigen sollen
Geschäfte die bei rohrgas bereits
Tradition haben
Pionier gewesen in der
Knüpfung der Kontakte nach Russland und
der Erschließung des Bezugs russischen
Erdgases
nach Deutschland doch
Bundeskartellamt und Monopolkommission
melden Bedenken an sie erteilen den
fusionsplänen eine klare Absage auch die
Monopolkommission hat gesagt das ist
kein guter Weg das ist auch kein guter
Weg um die Versorgungssicherheit zu
gewährleisten weil da gibt es viel
bessere Wege nämlich eine
Diversifizierung der Bezugsquellen also
andere Beschaffungsquellen
lng-terminals eine Verbreiterung des
Angebots das ist viel viel sinnvoller
als auf einen großen vertikal
integrierten Konzernen zu setzen
Warnungen die Bundeswirtschaftsminister
Werner Müller nicht hören will da er als
Ex-Manager des eonkonzerns befangen ist
schickt er seinen Staatssekretär Alfred
Tacke vor Tacke soll die Dinge richten
Attacke war aus Hannover gekommen war
Staat im Wirtschaftsministerium und dann
in Hannover war er
in die rechte Hand von Freude gewesen
wie die somit in allen
wirtschaftspolitischen Fragen eine sehr
wichtige Rolle kurz darauf präsentiert
Staatssekretär Tacke einen ministerlas
die offizielle Genehmigung der Fusion
zwischen E.ON und Orgas damit ist das
Veto der Wettbewerbshüter vom Tisch
einer Minister Erlaubnis
kann man gegen die Entscheidung
des Kartellamts
eine Fusion durchbekommen wenn sie
hinreichende Vorteile für das Gemeinwohl
bietet der Zusammenschluss bringt
wesentliche Gesamtwirtschaft die
Vorteile mit sich
er stärkt insbesondere die
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit der Burgas auf den
internationalen erdgasmärkten und trägt
damit langfristig zur Sicherung der
deutschen Energieversorgung bei was ist
eigentlich Versorgungssicherheit
geht es um stabile Preise geht es darum
dass
Lieferausfälle behoben werden es wurden
einfach
Krisenszenarien beschrieben in denen das
an alle die Fusion Wunder bewirken würde
ohne das gesagt wurde was
Versorgungssicherheit
die Fusion ruft die Wettbewerber auf den
Plan vor dem Düsseldorfer
Oberlandesgericht kommt es zur Klage
aber bevor der Prozess richtig beginnt
endet er auch schon die Kläger ziehen
ihre Klage zurück Eon hatte sie
ausbezahlt
die durch solche Vorgehensweisen
geschaffene Intransparenz trägt mit bei
zur Delegitimierung der Politik und sie
hat auch mit
gewirkt in dem weiteren Verfahren der
nachfolgenden 20 Jahre
nicht die einzige Wende Staatssekretär
Tacke und Minister Müller wechseln bald
darauf als Manager in den Konzernverbund
der mit ihrer Hilfe erst möglich wurde
die Fusion zwischen E.ON und rohrgas der
Auftakt für deutsch-russische
gasgeschäfte die alle bis dahin
bekannten Dimensionen übertreffen das
mitarbeitermagazin der ruhrgass AG mal
deine rosarote Zukunft Erdgas wird
ökologisch wie technisch der
attraktivste fossile Energieträger
bleiben
Rückendeckung gibt es von Kanzler
Schröder persönlich er erklärt die
deutsche russische Freundschaft zur
Chefsache und demonstriert immer wieder
gern seine tiefe Verbundenheit
Deutschland Gerät somit immer tiefer in
russische Abhängigkeit schließlich sogar
mit einer direkten Gaspipeline
nordstream 1 es ist das Prestigeprojekt
von Kanzler Schröder und Präsident Putin
Deutschland sichert in direkter
Partnerschaft mit Russland große Teile
seiner Energieversorgung auf Jahrzehnte
und ich nehme für mich in Anspruch dass
ich in langen Gesprächen mit dem Herrn
Präsidenten für einen Umfeld gesorgt
habe und er war Gott sei Dank auch
bereit dazu dass diese Form der
Zusammenarbeit ermöglicht hat auch die
Regierung Merkel hält weiter fest am pro
russischen Kurs zu einer Zeit wo längst
klar ist dass Russland Gas als
politisches Druckmittel einsetzt
und das zu einem Zeitpunkt wo wir
bereits 2010 eine gemeinsame Gast
diversifizierungsstrategie in der EU mit
deutscher Unterschrift verabschiedet
haben die ganz klar sagte wir müssen uns
als Lehre der gaskonflikte 2006 und
die Abhängigkeit von Russland reduzieren
und wir als größtes Mitgliedsland in der
EU als größter Importeur von russischem
Gas haben uns nicht an diese politische
Absprache gehalten und haben unsere
Abhängigkeit nochmals selbst nach 2014
weiter erhöht denn 2015 kommt es zum
Verkauf des größten deutschen
Gasspeichers an den russischen
Staatskonzern Gazprom russland hatte ein
Jahr zuvor die Krim besetzt trotz dieser
aggressiven russischen Expansionspolitik
denkt Bundeswirtschaftsminister Sigmar
Gabriel den Deal bedenkenlos durch das
heißt wir übertragen die Verantwortung
für das wichtigste Instrument der
deutschen Gasversorgung Sicherheit eines
der wichtigsten Instrumente die wir als
kritische Energieinfrastruktur
bezeichnen einem Staatskonzern eines
autoritären Staates noch bis zum Beginn
des ukraine-kriegs bezieht Deutschland
rund die Hälfte seines Erdgasbedarfs aus
Russland ein lukratives Geschäft das vor
allem in der Hand eines deutschen
Gasversorgers liegt junepar Juniper wird
2016 von Eon abgespalten als Mitgift
bekommt der neu gegründete Konzern das
deutsch-russische Gasgeschäft inklusive
eines Kundenstamms von über 100
Stadtwerken und Kunden aus der
Großindustrie
ist deshalb systemrelevant und muss mit
Steuergeldern in Milliardenhöhe vor der
Pleite gerettet werden alles nur
aufgrund einer folgenschweren
politischen Fehlentscheidung die 20
Jahre her ist
wäre das damals anders entschieden
worden hätten wir heute eine
vielfältigere
wettbewerbspolitisch sinnvollere
Situationen und eine Vielfalt von
Anbietern und eben nicht so eine große
Abhängigkeit von Russland insofern
glaube ich ja das war ein ganz wichtiger
Fehler jetzt müssen mit staatlicher
Hilfe flüssiggast Terminals im Eiltempo
an der deutschen Küste gebaut werden um
sich aus der russischen gasfalle zu
befreien die Lizenz zum Bau eines
solchen Terminals bis aus Eon seit
vielen Jahrzehnten 2009 aber gab sie der
Konzern ungenutzt zurück setzte
stattdessen alles auf die russische
Karte eine Fehlentscheidung für die
Deutschland nun bitter bezahlen muss
[Musik]